[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
good morning guys today is the big day
today is the day that we need to present
our research projects that we've been
working on throughout the year for a
conference this is as part of our
medical school degree and we will be
marked on this so we will be marked on
our presentation skills how good our
poster is how well we answer the
assessors or the examiner's questions so
i'll see in the conference
elizabeth
oh my god
how are you feeling
nervous but we'll be okay we'll be okay
i think we'll be fine we've done the
practices just like whether we can do it
as good as we did in the practice and
the right thing
yeah
exactly
[Music]
give me
how are you guys feeling now that it's
all done
relief but then we have another one in
like three days i know it never stops
does this
i'm just happy this one's done one down
more to hey we got this
[Music]
then i went to practice some clinical
skills
[Music]
then we baked the cake for our friend
emmy's birthday
and took it to her birthday party
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
i started my morning with some editing
then made a huge mistake by letting our
neighbors cat in
[Music]
[Music]
now that i'm partially moved on from
being upset about the damage my laptop
just had i can tell you guys about
today's plan so in the previous
conference i was talking about a gene
that can be used as a therapeutic target
in pancreatic cancer and in today's
conference i will be talking about how
doctors receiving notifications on their
phones about their patients test results
such as their patients blood test
results x-ray results can be used to
help with crowding and waiting times in
hospitals such as in nhs which is a
national health system in the uk so the
conference will be running from 9 00 am
till 5 pm so it's such a long conference
day but i'll see you guys there
[Music]
not mature
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
he's
[Music]
[Music]
currently the time is three past eleven
which is very late for me because i
usually go to bed around eight to nine
pm but i just wanted to edit today's
footage so it's all ready for you guys
for tomorrow now i'm just gonna do my
skincare and read my book this i
actually will finish my book because
i've got only four pages left
which i'm very excited about you know
when you have a book that you really
like or like a series that you really
like and you don't want it to finish
that's how i feel like but i need to
finish this tonight because i need to
catch up with my reading wish list but
then after that i'll go to sleep but
i've got so much videos planned for you
guys so i'm so excited for you to see us
all please do consider subscribing and
liking this video for now good night and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
so
[Music]